wie sollen wir eine sekunde über leben
in diesem deathmatch wir sind auf 8.200
dpi und 201 empfindlichkeit
moschitz und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute spielen wir ja
jump league und wir haben eine neue zorc
elternabend hallo und zwar laut kommt
die heutige zuschauerzahlen von niklas
seebode gesagt stell deine maus und
findigkeit so hoch wie es geht ok niklas
und jetzt hört man hin leute wir spielen
nicht mit 2.000 dpi wie normal nicht mit
handelt die bh und auch nicht mit
externen vor handelt die ph phpj alles
klar
leute dass gott der mit alter wenn ich
einfach nur einmal ball einfach mit der
maus schmackhafte gesehen mache ich
einfach der decks und 385 grad drehung
doch nur warum man das ist schon
verdammt die charity so mache und die
wären voll voll des spiegel vergeigt
alter mann die sondern zu spielen
eine sache wollte ich noch ansprechen
leute und zwar die band ich versuche
irgendwie irgendwie klar zu kommen und
nicht so frustriert zu sein von dem
spiel das ich aus dem fenster springen
muss gestern habe ich nie hochgeladen da
habe ich diese problematik jump liegt ja
erst mal angesprochen wo gott wohnt ja
ich will einfach nur quatschen dass ich
in die beides jetzt da kein beef haben
also ich hatte ihn sogar vor dem video
beschreitet die haupt von der libyschen
regierung ich möchte video machen indem
ich thematisiere wie das ist jetzt im
mittel mit jump wars und jump league und
so beim pass mine zuschauer behauptet
haben dass wir eben geklaut oder so dann
will ich mal darüber reden und den modus
mal vorstellen sie wussten also vorher
bescheid schon irgendwie ungefähr so
eine stunde vorm ab laut und waren
informiert auf jeden fall also das weiß
keiner
eine aktion die hinterrücks war oder so
und haben gemeint ja dass auch cool kann
sie gerne machen für die wir auch alles
gut
und die haben halt direkt nach dem
nachdem das video veröffentlicht wurde
vermutlich mein kommentar geschrieben um
einfach hundertprozentig sicher zu gehen
dass niemand in den kommentaren
irgendwie updated dem titel der halt
bisschen provokant war jump league
geklaut heißt das video seht ihr auf den
gestern weil ist ein bisschen provokant
titel die mache ich ja gerne da habe ich
so eine schwäche für leute ich weiß ich
weiß es nicht gut aber kann sich ändern
aber heute ist gerade halbwegs ist
häufig sehr schön hier
nein nein ich bin doch einfach nur mit
einer sau geil aussehen denn wenn ich
meine maus nicht bewege aber wenn ich
meine maus ab ist ein kleines stück
bewege sagt 8000 8000 verdammte dpi ihr
wisst ihr was wir machen können
wir können auch noch mal die warum
schreibst du bist wie es im chat zu wem
das mega gemeint ok nice wir können auch
gleich noch mal wir den nächsten
checkpoint erreicht haben noch mal einen
level drauf packen und noch mal in
minecraft die sensitivität hochstellen
wenn das geht ich weiß es nicht
steuerung maus empfindlichkeit ist jetzt
auf 100 und jetzt turbo okay nein nein
leute 8000 ging gerade noch irgendwie
aber jetzt mit turbo in minecraft misst
gott oh gott nein leute wie soll ich
damit das mitspielen
was ist dass man ich versuche meine maus
einfach nur gerade zu halten
ich schwöre euch ich versuche ich halte
meine maus einfach gerade ich bin was
ich kann diese kiste ich schwöre ich
kann diesen punkt nicht finden
da sie mit dem ihr eine kiste gehen kann
ok hier sagt okay alles klar
was soll mit der suche bespringen als ob
das geht die maus gerade halten maus
gerade halten und es geht ja jetzt nicht
da also weiß ich schwöre euch euer gott
diese maus ein alter gerade eben 8000
gegen also von 2000 auf 8.200 war schon
eine krasse steigerung aber dann godwin
pumps oben wo es unten was da hier lange
aber dann in minecraft normal auf turbo
zu stellen das war jetzt absolut ok also
das ist jetzt wirklich endgültig und
spielbar aber wissen was witzig wird die
werden im deathmatch safe denken dass
ich den weg drin hab diesen effekt nicht
überblicken wo man sich also ultras
dreht wissen was wir schon steht man
jetzt mal eine kleine f5 premiere davon
wie das aussieht wenn ich bis in die
maus bewegen so wenn ich die maus und
bisschen bewegen sieht es aber so aus
ein schleichender und bis in die luft
und dann werden alle denken ich abhängig
ist aber nicht aus gerade halten
es ist halt echt fast ein spieler allein
hier die richtung mit nein
nötig ist die maus gerade gehalten die
schwarz ich schwöre es euch jetzt noch
mal hoch obwohl alles klar
allein die drehung nach rechts machen
auch sie an der leitha festzuhalten die
hab ich das gut gemacht wenn er mal kurz
mir sagen ich das gemacht habe
ich komme ich komme einfach nicht hin
alleine hätte vor dem chat mit gold
abgeschlossen
das heißt es kommt jetzt okay wir können
nicht weiter wir müssen uns und uns darf
anziehen bleibe auch keine schätz plate
als ob wie soll wie sollen wir eine
sekunde über leben in diesen deathmatch
wohnen spade wir sind auf 8.200 dpi und
200 prozent witzigkeit in minecraft
warum spielen wir eigentlich noch was
man ihm an bitte schauen sie mich
ziemlich nicht nein nein nein warum nein
nein nein nein ich bin unschuldig ich
kann kann nicht nein nein oder gebremste
brennt gott ich fühlte mich wie der
größte markt ist rekord ach du ich
treffen nichts man soll ich schwöre euch
treff gar nichts
ich schwöre euch ich treff gar nicht
okay wenn das so nicht geht dann müssen
wenigsten leute davon überzeugen
da kommt der kommt er kommt er kommt der
kommt lauf lauf um dein leben laufenden
leben sohn laufenden leben leute bitte
erwartet nicht sofort ich schwöre ich
wirklich ich schwöre wirklich ich würde
liebend gerne richtig pvp spiel aber es
geht nicht dass man jemand aua aber nein
nein nein nein nein nein ich mache nicht
noch nicht macht nicht mache ich 30 kids
einfach
fucking 0 kills wirklich leute was ich
schwöre euch das ist uns spielen wird es
mal zu hause und schreibt wenn man die
kommentare wie das bei euch rief ich
schwöre euch pvp ist damit um
überall ist kein scherz jetzt nicht so
okay dann muss bisschen üben dann gehts
es ist einfach cool spiel seht ihr dass
ich bewegt meine maus um 1 mm und ich
bin habe ich 180 grad gedreht das ist zu
viel
ich glaube ich schließe meine
youtube-kanal ganz ehrlich dass ich hab
zu viel von diesen changes einfach